thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
yes it is packed the NBA is back money
is about to be made I hope you are as
excited as we are uh I'm going to the
game actually Sam I Am will be there
tonight the Warriors are getting their
Rings tonight I will be in attendance uh
taking one of the BR betting fans and we
are going to be riding all day on The
Bleacher Report betting story so make
sure you guys check us out on the BR
betting Story the three by two Sam one
of our favorite bets the three by two
parlay boost that's two three-pointers
in the first three minutes for the new
people that do not know uh FanDuel is
boosting this one for a Sam they're
boosting the 3x2 parlay the 3x2 has hit
in both the warriors uh no the three by
two has to hit Sam it has to hit in both
the Warriors Lakers and the Sixers
Celtics games and we're boosting it from
plus 330 to to plus 400 you guys are
welcome that leads me to this Sam that
leads me to let's start the show let's
start the show welcome to the show
everybody next to me is the man the myth
the legend Sam Richmond uh Sam how we
feeling today
great man NBA it's it's insane that the
NBA is back I'm so excited and we got a
great slate tonight so uh let's try and
win some money too
great slate we're trying to win money we
also got my man producer Ryan in the
chat talking to the people producer Ryan
how we feeling bro NBA's back brother
hold on wait wait before before you even
give a take me you the last time we did
this show or the last time the show was
on yeah we were going at it because my
Warriors beat your Boston Celtics so how
we feeling after a uh off season of um
not winning the championship well that
that was my Peak my the Celtics were are
gonna be in the NBA Finals I'll Never
See happiness like that again I'm
convinced so it's all downhill from here
for the Celtics uh I'm at an all-time
low in terms of in terms of uh optimism
I'm a pretty big pessimist going into
this year so not not great
Ryan's not feeling great so Ryan we're
going to send you back to the chat go
back to the chat go get better go go
talk to your Celtics fans and right now
right now my man Sam Richmond the man
the myth the legend is about to give us
six Best Bets that he loves so Sam
take it away but before you take it away
I need everybody drop your Best Bets in
the chat and we'll talk about as many as
we can but right now right now Sam you
got the spotlight brother take it away
all right we're gonna start off with
with a real Banger that you and the
audience is sure to hate but we are
going with the Lakers tonight plus seven
I know it's gross I get it I think to me
this is just a motivation play right
like the Warriors really have nothing to
prove this game doesn't really matter
them they're Champs they're made men it
doesn't matter the Lakers kind of need
to not get embarrassed on the national
stage tonight after just how bad last
year was and all the dramas trying to
the team I think you're going to see a
really high level of intensity to them
maybe not like playoff level intensity
but pretty close
um and I just think it's a lot of points
right it's a lot of points and you have
LeBron and A.D healthy when the Lakers
have struggled in past years it's
because either one of those or both
those guys has been out they've actually
been pretty good when both of them are
on the court you have them rested after
a long off season seven points a lot I
like
wow I mean you you hit us you hit us
right on time you were right on time as
far as the clock but you got me confused
brother you talk about motivation who
doesn't want to play and win on ring
night Sam they're getting their Rings
tonight they can't just get rings and
then lose like I don't know they can
they don't why do they care they just
wanna they're gonna have fun like
they're gonna go party afterwards
they're Champions that doesn't matter
uh I don't know about that one I'm going
to the game and I want to see a win so
uh producer Ryan producer Run come into
the fold here come into the fold talk
about the chat talk about what they're
saying do they like Sam's pick or are
they on my side leaning against it I
mean we did see this Laker team in the
preseason right Sam did you not see them
play in the preseason they're just
getting ready for the regular season you
know they're getting all the bad losses
out of the way
they don't need to win they just need to
cover seven points seven points is a lot
yeah so the the chat is doing what it
usually does which is uh disregarding
the points I have t Duvall in here
saying Lakers money line uh we've got
Sean padrina saying Warriors money line
I believe the Warriors money line is
minus 300 just delay it's a leg it's a
leg right it's a shirt so yeah another
like GMO uh Steph 26 plus points how do
you feel about that Greg oh I'll
absolutely love that 20 only 20.
on no 26 26. oh 26 26 I love that I love
that Steph's got to go Steph's gotta go
Steph go we go okay and then we got C
Jax saying you'll love this Greg Lakers
getting run out of the building tonight
oh yeah absolutely is Westbrook even
starting we don't know anyway producer
Ryan back to the chat please we will see
you later Sam you gave us a horrible
first play but that is okay brother that
is okay I respect it and honestly from a
betting perspective not being a fan I
don't dislike it but uh here we go you
got the next play here talk to me talk
to the people you got 45 seconds on the
clock go
all right I like the 76ers plus three in
the other game
I I really like this Philly team this
year I'm buying James Harden getting
into shape he's heard all the criticism
from the past few years he's been hurt I
think he got healthy I think he got in
shape I really like the additions they
made this off season Melton Harrell PJ
Tucker they added some toughness and I
think the Celtics are going to be fine
long term but I do think there is going
to be adjustment period with everything
that is surrounding that franchise right
now to go against a really good Philly
team with everything that is going on
with the new coach and all the drama and
they have some serious injuries on this
team with Robert Williams not there and
obviously Gallo's out for the year I
think it's going to take some time so I
like the Sixers getting the points
tonight
I love that stuff and you want some time
on the clock you gave us two seconds
back I absolutely love that place Sam uh
that should be the squad ride of the day
I'm not gonna live you guys don't know
or didn't hear or I guess you guys are
hearing now but let's just make that the
squad ride of the day Sam six or plus
two and a half I absolutely love it Sam
this is called six Best Bets you gave us
two that means you have four remaining
you gave us a really good pick with the
Sixers one I love that I'm actually
about to put that one in as you talk
about this next pick well good because
you're not gonna like this one so I try
and mix in a one you'll like and a one
you won't like so I never lose you too
much but uh I like the Nuggets this year
nuggets 20 to 1 to win the NBA title
we're going Futures I like the Nuggets
look I think it's a really big deal that
they're getting Murray and mpj back uh
the fact that they were as good as they
were last year missing two of their top
three guys I think was really impressive
they're really but they're pretty deep
this year too they've made some really
good off-season acquisitions uh I really
like kcp and Bruce Brown and you've got
Aaron Gordon as well I think if they
stay healthy if Murray and mpj stay
healthy I think they can compete among
the top of the West and I think 20-1 is
just a really really good number so I I
think it's worth a flight on the nuggets
Sam you literally made me stop doing
what I was doing on my phone because I I
heard you say the Nuggets to win the
game
you must didn't see the preseason game
of the Warriors facing the Nuggets like
a couple a couple days ago where I don't
know never mind I think the words in it
ended up losing that game but when the
stars was in they were up 10. anyway uh
nuggets
not plus 2 000 that's your third pick
Sam you got three more
also also this this does need to be
mentioned when it comes to Futures my
man Sam is usually on point I don't know
what happened today but that is okay
that that that is okay my man's usually
on point he probably got one for us next
Sam talk to us what's next brother all
right this is another one I really like
we're going Keegan Murray rookie of the
year I think it's around plus 460. look
I think a lot of people were critical
when the Kings took Keegan Murray over
Jayden Ivy and I still would have taken
Ivy but Murray has looked amazing he lit
up Summer League he looked really good
in preseason
um he has been great and I think
um I think he's going to be starting
soon I know he's not going to be
initially starting but I think he's
going to score a lot of points I think
he's going to be in the starting lineup
soon and I think this Kings team is
going to be sneaky decent and I think if
they can somehow work their way into the
play-in and maybe get lucky and get into
the playoffs by winning the play-in
that's a a really nice Narrative of a
new player coming in and helping a team
build beat a really long playoff drought
kind of like what Julio Rodriguez did
for the Mariners a little cross sport
reference for you I know I went over but
uh but I like Keegan Murray there it is
Sam there it is uh I I don't dislike
that one man Keegan Murray he's a baller
he was balling last year in college I
want to see how that game translates to
the NBA
we will see while them Sacramento Kings
fan out uh this year Sam that's four you
got two more to go talk to me talk to
the people remember 45 seconds Sam this
next time I'm cutting you off bro I I
got it I love the time I left on the
other one carried over if I like ended
five seconds early
um this isn't singular bro this isn't
singular back in like 2004 if you guys
don't know that it was a telephone
company back in the day no it doesn't
roll over the time don't roll over here
it's 45 seconds and you got 45 seconds
now brother
all right uh we're going in win totals
and I'm taking the Charlotte Hornets
under 34 and a half wins this team is
just a complete mess and obviously the
situation with Miles Bridges goes Way
Beyond basketball in terms of importance
but they are not they won't have him
this year and that is a really big hit
they're not going to have lamelo ball to
start the season and I think a thing
that I want people to pay attention to
this year is the tanking is going to be
out of control for this draft class with
winbanyana and Scoot Henderson and if
you get a team like the Hornets who
struggle early I think they're going to
sell off their veterans and just be like
hey we started three and eleven let's
just tank and try and get a really good
draft pick and you're going to see some
really low win totals this year
foreign
I gotta take a step back and think about
that one bro if we got lamelo with wait
help me pronounce it I always butcher
his name the number one yeah
yeah lamelo with him running the pick
and roll
that guy is generational and teams are
going to go out of their way to tank for
him it is going to be insane you're
going to see multiple teams with like 19
wins 20 wins and I think the Hornets
again they're still at 34 and a half
wins I think they are going to make that
decision hey we need to suck even more
because we're not making the playoffs
man Sam now you really got me thinking
you really got me thinking over here man
Godly if that was to happen oh that
franchise will be in good good hands uh
in the future in the future all right
Sam you got me over here thinking I know
you like those future bets I know you
like those future bets you just gave us
one you have another one for us you have
a play tonight what we thinking for this
last and final pick I got one more
Joelle embiid to an MVP look MVP is a
narrative award everyone knows that and
I think it really sets up nicely for him
be this year he's gotten really close
the past few years and lost and I think
that sort of like snubbed guy who's
gotten close really works into his favor
we saw it with James Harden a few years
ago where he kept getting second kept
getting second and voters want to reward
that guy and say hey it's his time his
time to win I think you're gonna see
that with embiid this year I think that
Philly team like I said is going to be
really good if they can get the first or
second seed and indeed puts up similar
numbers to what he did last year he's
not going to have jokets to worry about
because they're not giving it a joke at
your third year in a row uh I think this
in beads year I think the narrative
Works in his favor and I think this is
good value
there it is Sam I like how you ended I
like how you ended right on time right
there brother uh MP embiids mvpi like
that I like that we'll see if Joelle
takes that step up this year and
that Sixers team can James Harden is he
going to look like James Harden of old I
guess we will have to see Ryan lost 100
pounds this summer that's what he said
I I saw I saw that producer Ryan
we need two things two things from you
one we need you to fact check if James
Harden actually dropped 100 pounds this
year he did two two
figure out he does look good he does
look good we need you to actually not
figure out but tell us what's going on
in the chat brother yeah Sam listen I'm
on the Sixers too but this is way too
much Philadelphia propaganda for me uh
way too much uh Jimbo says Celtics are
finishing what they started last year uh
only worry tonight is embiid and he
cannot single-handedly beat the Celtics
uh Sean padrinas also on the Sixers with
you saying slim Hardin
um Chef K Peezy saying the Sixers
definitely the best bet of the day
uh see jux
chicken McNuggets you might as well burn
your money
doesn't like your nuggets future yeah I
was I didn't get that but okay yeah yeah
the McNuggets part yeah yeah yeah but uh
we honestly do as well have uh some
pretty positive uh Kings Vibes in here I
won't lie uh hunch says he likes Keegan
uh uh Mike Ritter jumping in the chat
saying Pacers might win seven games uh
on your
seriously like with these bad teams I
would take the unders because it's going
to be unprecedented levels of tanking
this year yeah got some Luca MVP takes
in here uh yeah Zion most improved
player uh I'm not sure improved comeback
players averaging like 27 and eight but
he was comfy so I kind of want to know
how much more improved he can get yeah
so the tanks are hot in this chat uh a
lot of agreeing some disagreeing too
many Philadelphia Vibes again but this
is this is what you want this is this is
your dream so this is this is exactly
what you want uh NBA's back so we're all
excited we are all excited make sure you
guys drop your picks drop your own picks
in the chat and we will we will get to
those later producer Ryan
back to the chat brother uh let's talk
tonight's game let's talk tonight's
games Lakers Warriors Sixers Celtics
once again drop you guys locks in the
chat I'm going to the game tonight Sam
and we all want to see Steph and LeBron
shoot it out so
producer Ryan come on back come on back
you don't have to be in the chat so long
we sent him away for 10 seconds and now
we're bringing him back I don't know how
I feel about that pull up those FanDuel
pull up those odds for FanDuel there
they are go to the folks you see it
right there under our three by two
booths we talked about that one earlier
uh there it is Steph and LeBron click it
click it go ahead and click it Ryan
there it is Steph and LeBron to go over
50 plus points
Sam talk to me I like this I can see you
know Steph getting 40 maybe LeBron
getting 10. and that's cash in this bet
so I mean I like it absurd man take off
take off the Warriors jersey you got
you're you're you're insane
um no I do like it I think look that's
that's around both those guys averages
getting 25 plus
um like I do think you're going to see a
super motivated LeBron stuff is
obviously I'm his biggest stuff guy in
the world so at plus 150 that is a very
very nice boost so uh I think you gotta
ride that I mean I I like to go to games
and sometimes I want action on both
sides you know what I mean I just so I
can stay involved into the in the game
stay uh focused on the game and you know
possibly walk home with some money so
this is one I can see I can see
happening 50 plus points LeBron Steph
Steph go get 40 burn go get 10 yeah all
right here we go Ryan talk to us about
the chat talk to us about the chat
what are they talking about what are
they liking tonight all right so we got
Ryan branscome saying Harden over eight
and a half assists how do you guys feel
about that
I like it man I like it I I think it's
gonna be very good this year
Sam let's
flip bro because
over eight and a half yeah eight and a
half I think he's gonna have to come out
doing his thing no shot Sam gives gives
this an a no shot I'll give it an a for
The Vibes wow and because uh my paper is
all over the place we have we have too
much paper on the show these days
a lot of paper on the show a lot of
paper on the show hey Sam but this this
Falls in with your Sixers big man James
Harden has to go off
in order for them to win tonight so
I like it I think that's the first a
Sam's ever given on any of these I know
I kind of regret it uh I'm gonna go back
to just always giving bees for now but
again I got I'm in a new new place for
today's show so I'm all over the place
okay uh blue season new season new sand
yeah there you go uh Mari saying
Warriors money line 76ers money line
parlay
oh what's the pay out there there it is
that's where it is I mean that's
probably like
160. no I'm probably more than that like
plus 180.
give me give uh plus 209. love it love
it I mean I do think the Warriors win
tonight like I'm not taking Lakers money
line but I do like LA to cover
okay
uh well actually Sam wait hold on gotta
give him a uh there it is I'm giving
that person an a because I'm actually
going to place that bet as soon as I'm
done with the show you're gonna make me
find my B Greg too much paper
be okay all right and then uh and then
last one and then we'll move on uh uh
Sean padrina LeBron passing Hakeem this
year for the all-time scoring record
s
do we know he said I'm like Ron Burgundy
you whatever you write I'm gonna read
Fair
yeah he's definitely gonna break it I
think it's a matter of when right like
yeah yeah he's gonna break it
I'm gonna give this guy a c though
because he has to come with some more
context on like agreed yeah
the right name would help too so
he gets an effort yeah F minus there you
go uh but yeah keep uh everyone in the
chat keep dropping your picks keep
dropping your locks uh we'll get to it
we'll grade them later on in the show uh
but yeah that's a chat guys
all right here we go
we heard your favorite player props for
tonight we also put our favorites in
this same game parlay Ryan
talk to the people tell them what's up
all right so we got our same game parlay
here
plus 473. we've got four legs LeBron
six plus assists
Anthony Davis 20 plus points
Steph Curry the three-point King four
plus threes and then Klay Thompson to
score 15 plus all for that for the late
game
plus 473 so you could tail us on FanDuel
or what you can do
what you can what you can do is you can
uh create your own no sweat same game
parlay or same game plus parlay on
FanDuel uh I believe it's a Max fifty
dollar free bet you get back if it loses
uh has to be at least plus 400 odds so
you could do that it's available tonight
through Thursday on FanDuel so take
advantage of that while you can but guys
what do you think about what do you
think about RC game parlay
well that's great that that's the the no
sweat so if we do lose people can't yell
at us because you're getting your money
back anyway so that that makes me happy
right
that's true
I don't know I don't know I might be
sweating on this one to be honest
step four threes in the game one you
guys think that he's gonna do that I
don't know but listen like Sam said it's
no sweat so if it's up to fifty dollars
you could toss fifty dollars on it feel
pretty good about it that you'll get it
back in a free BET and if it hits that's
236 dollars in your pocket
got you and if you don't you can put it
on a parlay that you like more than ours
so you know it's a win-win yeah it's a
win right yeah so uh also if you're a
new customer you bet five dollars
tonight and get a guaranteed 150 in free
bets and three months of NBA league pass
for free I'm paying for my NBA league
pass so take advantage of this while you
can three plus months of NBA League Pass
are you kidding me
three
right I might need your login so we can
we can talk about that after the show
but I mean if we get the three months
then uh that's true yeah yeah hey three
months for the F that's jug that's
that's that's what we call jug uh but
let's transition guys let's talk Futures
drop your favorite Futures in the chat
y'all probably already know my favorite
future
is
is drum roll oh wait Sam's yeah Sam I
wonder where Greg is gonna go with this
I think we I think we have odds on this
actually so oh good what are so for
Greg's future to be Golden State to win
it all yes is minus 5500 no plus 4 500.
there's a lot of value on no but yes
seems to be a lock
you said there's a lot of value on Note
well guys I wasn't going there with my
future but I do think the Golden State
Warriors will win the championship I
will say that but that is not my future
bet guys that is not my future bet so
everybody that chose no you guys are
riding with a lot of money uh according
to these odds but all right here we go
my future bet is guys drumroll
Jordan Poole he just got a lucrative
contract deal
six men of the year he's going to be in
that second unit with James Wiseman
Jonathan kaminga they're going to be
ballers in that second unit for the
Golden State Warriors and Jordan Poole
is going to be the point guard for that
second he's going to have the ball in
his hands I think he's going to put up a
lot a lot of impressive numbers this
season and he's gonna have to take a
step up from last season and taking a
step up from last season is going to go
when six men of the year so it's Plus
450.
go get it now
how do you guys feel like oh Greg like
played it off like no no I'm not taking
the words from the title and yes he's
not taking the words from the title
you're taking a Warriors player to win
an award so uh I think it's like a push
for our audience that took yes on uh
well Greg take the words from the title
I think that's a push they get their
money back yeah hey Sam you're a good
you're such a good Casino I I would love
to bet with your Casino if you're giving
money back for that
Jesus uh but but Ryan talk to me talk
how you feeling about Jordan Jordan pool
six men in a year plus 450. wow
yeah it might it might depend on who's
who's on the court for the Warriors on
how much he'll get the ball but uh I
mean he's talented for sure you don't
get that kind of contract and and don't
have the talent to be able to do that so
plus 450 I feel like two months into the
season that might be closer to even
money so I would take it
there it is hey Ryan do you have your
eye on any Futures though oh I
absolutely love Giannis to win MVP love
it plus 700 on FanDuel love it love it
love it love it yes yeah for me I think
the the only real bets that I I looked
at for MVP were indeed Giannis and Zion
is kind of a flyer but yeah my same take
for embiid I would use for Rihanna so if
they get the one seed and he puts up the
numbers he did last year he is a really
really good chance to win so Sam I like
the sprinkle I love the sprinkle that
you just mentioned Zion Zion stays
healthy
the hand is so good man like people
forgot he is going to remind people this
year he's also you want to talk about
hearted slimming down Zion slim down oh
yeah oh yeah it looks great looks great
I'm not gonna lie Zion needs to hit up
Braun and ask Braun what does he do for
his body and then you know try to
implement that into his uh off-season
workouts because Zion did come back
looking really really really good Ryan
the chat what are they like what are
they talking about Sam do you have your
papers ready are you ready to grade
some pigs I'm ready let's do it I wanna
I kind of want to start off with a weird
one I like this one caught my eye as
soon as I saw it uh we have Pete black
saying Karis Levert
Sixth Man of the Year
oh
what's what's the number there
I don't dislike that Charis Levert
Carousel he's a baller yeah he is a
baller fun fact I think he's related to
the to The OJ's or something like that I
don't know if that's you guys fact
checked me so right now I FanDuel
doesn't have the season awards up for me
to look at so I can't I can't call out
the number there
it's okay it's okay I am seeing plus 4
900 actually I'm sorry
that's good value
it is good value I will say uh you know
I I hate to give Greg credit but uh I do
think uh I do think it is Poole's award
to lose
um so but I don't hate it I think it's
good value but uh but uh the Warrior
season would have to go pretty
disastrous for pool not to win that
award in my mind
gotcha uh Sugar Shane Zion comeback
player of the year
that is not an award in the in the NBA I
believe again like I said Ron Burgundy
whatever you type in here I will read I
promise
yeah 99 sure uh I think maybe he's
looking for most improved but again same
thing there I don't think come back play
of the years
so I'm giving that an F if I can find it
f minus f for producer Ryan for reading
it uh franley C BR Malcolm Brogden Sixth
Man of the Year
is he nice I mean it's interesting
no he's not starting no that's Plus
1600.
yeah I mean
I I just don't I think he is actually a
really great piece for that team I just
don't think he's going to put up the
numbers because there's too many mouths
to feed on that team
um yeah yeah like it's not going to be
like what Greg is talking about with the
Warriors like where Jordan Poole is
going to be running that second team
like you're still going to have JB or
Tatum out there correct me if I'm wrong
Ryan but I don't think he's going to be
running the show offensively on those
second teams no he wouldn't be
um you also yeah guys like Grant
Williams are still there as well so like
yeah the Celtics are pretty deep and I
think they're his main contribution I
think you'll see is just like in the
success of the Celtics rather than like
100 wow he's great yeah uh Fabian Cantu
Rookie of the Year Benedict matheran
oh I mean I think he's gonna be really
good that team is going to stink like
he's going to put up a lot of points
he's gonna be playing a lot of minutes I
I'd give it a b if I can I can find it
um not a ton of value on that one it's
only plus 650 in comparison to the other
ones that we've said but
why don't we get back right it's fine
see see
we'll see that's why I gave it a c
because we'll see I like that I like
that a lot uh
Ryan branscrum well we'll finish on this
one and we'll give we'll get let Greg uh
finish up some good vibes Warriors over
51 and a half wins
how many pluses next to the A
there's no pluses but just no next
it's a plus plus plus plus plus plus
plus plus plus
oh yeah I like that one I like this
players are like not gonna try as much
in the regular like they're you don't
think their eyes are going to be towards
the playoffs see my thing is though Sam
their twos is like just as good as a lot
of teams wants so it's like you know we
can go out there that like in the
preseason we we went out there and I
think it was the Portland Portland uh
Trailblazers we played and we we threw
out ran our twos out there and they went
crazy so like I really think that the
Warriors twos is better than some ones
and I think in those games that you're
talking about where they're probably
resting the starters or they're playing
the twos more that the twos is going to
still be able to carry team so 51 Ryan
yeah on FanDuel it's actually so the
chat was 51 and a half on FanDuel it's
52 and a half and it's plus 100 if you
take the over so would you still take
that
taking it yeah okay you need a you need
a second sheet of paper for the amount
of pluses you would put next to a A plus
money I like that I I like you guys know
that I like plus money hey but we've
reached the end of our show producer
Ryan thank you for all all the comments
thank you guys for all the comments Sam
thank you for your six Best Bets uh if
you guys didn't catch the six Best Bets
pretty sure you guys can catch them on
our social channels go to Sam's Twitter
page I'm pretty sure he hasn't posted
everywhere on this Twitter feed uh for
Sam Richmond and producer Ryan I'm Greg
Ivory we
are out of here I got to get to a game
guys peace
foreign